hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for part four of our webinar series
on 3d culture and analysis this
presentation we are about to show you
was broadcast live during our 24 hours
of stem cells virtual event you may
submit questions during the presentation
and throughout the on-demand period we
encourage you to participate and to do
so simply type your questions into the
ask a question box and click the send
button your questions will be addressed
via email following the presentation
additionally we will be hosting a live
roundtable discussion with R&D leaders
in the coming months we will alert you
via email when we open registration it
is now time for our webinar presented by
dr. Takanori tech heavy and moderated by
Mark Kennedy to review products and
educational materials that can get you
started in 3d
make sure to visit thermo Fisher comm
forward slash organoid
you
everyone and welcome to today's
presentation titled modeling
inflammation and fibrosis and humans
with PSC derived steatohepatitis liver
organoids presented by Takanori - cafe
associate director of the center for
stem-cell and organized medicine and
professor at Cincinnati Children's
Hospital as well as professor at Tokyo
medical and dental University and
professor and principal investigator at
Yokohama City University my name is Mark
Kennedy a thermo Fisher Scientific and
I'll be your moderator for today's
presentation so before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting any questions
you may have at any time during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation so if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please use the ask a question box to let
us know of any technical technical
difficulties so with that please allow
me to introduce dr. - Kevin so dr. -
cafe is an associate director of the
Center for stem-cell and organized
medicine also known as custom at the
Cincinnati Children's Hospital Medical
Center as I mentioned he's also
professor at Yokohama City University
and Tokyo medical and dental University
of Japan he serves as on the board of
directors at the International Society
of stem cell research and his lab
investigates the mechanisms of human
organogenesis and he developed many
organoid or many organ technologies from
human stem cells namely organ bud based
approaches he is applying IPSC liver
buds into drug discovery as well as
transplant applications for patients
with a rare congenital metabolic
disorder ultimately expanding the
clinical indications to diseases like
liver cirrhosis and with that i'd like
to thank dr. tu kabhi for joining us and
I will now turn the presentation over to
him
thank you so much for the kind of
introduction and good good evening I
think to everyone and I'm I'm in Japan
and good morning from Japan and my name
is taka taka Ava and thank you so much
for some Fisher members for giving me
this very high-tech opportunity to
present our listen we're actually
related to organoid so I just rightly
modified my presentation title so the
ear of Medicine to cover the more
broader perspective of what we are
working on using the human proponents
themselves all right so I just a little
bit about great thanks to my members in
the different labs so I'm currently
learning five different ruble trees in
in Cincinnati Children's in Oklahoma
City University in the middle and
akhator a joint program in a together
pharmaceutical and Design Center which
is a little different from my talk and
also Tokyo Medical Dental University
especially I like to appreciate doctor
Taniguchi who is also the professor at
the Oklahoma City University and and we
are working very closely for the
translational application / liberal
organic based approaches and also I'd
like to thank for the funding agencies
including that aim at jst jsps and nice
F and indicator for Masuda call as well
and also collaborator as well so I'm
working in a Cincinnati Children's at
custom and I am really grateful for the
tremendous support from the custom
faculty members at Cincinnati Children's
and also she Yamanaka working at the
color University is providing us the the
fantastic stem cell source which is
namely an IPS cells for the
translational applications and with that
I'd like to start my presentation so
just as the way of background so I'm
regionally interested in transparent
sergeant surgery especially for the
liver transplantation so so this is the
first patient I actually met in the
United States and when I was taking the
internship at
Columbia University so as I said here is
how us but their patient I met there who
are Japanese patients who is mr. Asano
and he was very sort of lucky guy
because he was diagnosed as the very
severe liver failure back in Japan but
unfortunately there are very limited
number of transplants in Japan because
of probably because the limited
conscience so his only option was to fry
outside Japan to get a whole liver
transplantation in elsewhere outside
Japan and he was just flying into the
Columbia University and finally be able
to be transplanted by the whole liver
transplant approaches and now he is
completely coming from the disease and
back in Japan and working at their
elementary school teachers house before
so he was very lucky to be transplanted
but but I think behind the scenes I
think we are missing the very severe
statistics like this one so this is the
studied statistics from the United
States and for the transplantations so
as you see from the blue bar is starting
from the early 1990s and the demand or
waiting patients for the whole organ
transplantation is growing over time
very intensively but in contrast actual
transplant case indicate by Greenberg he
remains stable which simply suggested
that the gap is growing and almost
hundreds of thousands of patients are
just waiting to die so this is really
catastrophic and very sad so I decided
to jump into the different field which
is namely a stem cell and organ or u2 to
make a difference for the the patients
are waiting for the transplantation so
so so to do that we are very interested
in the overnight technologies so this
just show you the review papers
published by nature authored by the
cassandra and back in 2015 and as you
see here there are a number of different
program organoid technologies are coming
out for the past few years including the
Blaine organoid and we were all annoyed
a gastric organoid and in so forth
and you know the dr. society a working
at the RIKEN is I think the one of the
founder for disputed by publishing a
paper for the optic cup organoid paper
and also Hans creepers lab and dr. Toshi
Sato is developing a method for
developing a gastric organoid from the
adult stem cell populations followed by
many outstanding investigators in the
world to develop multiple different
organs I just wondered the beauty the
background of the variation of the organ
or field in the next right so organ or
is initially defined in early 90s a
growing steadily over time but for the
past few years the the number of
publications for organ on is growing
intensely as in this slide so I think
throughout the the abrasion process I
think very lovely summarizing I think
there are many three major contributing
technologies driving the organized
evolution field so for instance if you
look at be organized 1.0 version one I
think this is the initial of foundation
of the orgonite energies
so dr. Wilson is working with the sea
sponge sea animals and found that if you
dissociated the sea sponge into the
single cells and reallocating them in a
small well you found the the entire
system structures can be reformed by the
videography qualities so so I think the
aggregation found in the early 90s is
clearly a very important
technologies to to look at the
self-organization potential which is a
critical aspects for making organoid but
afterwards it turns out the more higher
animals like lowland models or monkey
model I think still it's very
challenging to make an old and I from
just an aggregate and to tackle this
mean of the cell and other pioneering
scientists are using Lehrer mean in
which extracellular matrix component or
in general are known as materials it's
really important for for in neighboring
the self-organization into organoid so
combining with the lee aggregate with
Matthew Johnson loving in with GCM she
and many of the investigators found dog
we even for the dilaudid model we can
make an organized including the mammary
organoid or cuny argan oil and organize
another version 3 I think this is the
major driver for the organ oil are
increasing almond fabrication is the
human stem cell technologies so
including the adults themselves into
important stem cells including the
embryonic stem cells or iPS cells so
having that adult stem cell source or a
pluripotent stem cell source
dr. society and dr. creepers found out
the methods to make a human specific
organ oil and this was followed by a
series of investigators including Jim
wells in dr. Taniguchi in dr. Norwich in
machine Okamura Marissa little to make a
gutful deny or okay no gotta organize or
our brain and so forth but today I'm
going to really focusing on the future
of organ which I think the organ of
medicine or application of organize for
the medical applications so so for the
past 3 version of organ donation was
really driven by the method to make an
oval but uh but it turns out we are now
able to make a sort of humor miniature
version of organ so I think we
for the future I think I'm really
interested in the promise of application
of organ into the medical miracle fuel
to accelerate this process at Cincinnati
Children's
we are recently establish our new center
called custom center floral stem cell on
organic medicine so all odds on who is a
noted developmental biologist in a
liberal field well land field is a
difference is the director for the
custom and code directed by Jim James
Wells and Mike Hellmuth and myself
Angie Wells it's working on a number of
GI orgonite including in gastric or
intestinal or ROG intestinal organ as
well and Michaelmas is our surgeon and
clinician scientist in developing a
method to transplant the index of
organoid
to model the human development in bebo
so so we are establishing a very
critical infrastructures to increase the
access to the organ or technologies
including the core laboratories
including gene editing core or imaging
quarter or or epigenetics core and so
forth and to help the creation scientist
to use the very high-tech approaches for
the the the ogen research and also we
are developing a blanket ILP which
enables the the the collection of the
human iPS cells or event way to develop
organize as a banking strategies from
the layout disease patients as well as
healthy patient populations and also we
are developing accelerator
bubble trees which is I think very
unique infrastructures to enable the
interaction between the academia and
industry so we are welcoming the
industry scientists with a close
proximity to our economic laboratories
and to be able to for instance screening
VD drugs in our organic system for the
commercial prototyping and also we have
the
Kuniko gray a GMP laboratory for the
tissue processing processing in a
clinical level so these sort of four
major our accelerator components is
helping the scientist to to to use the
organize for the medical applications
and we are actually dividing the four
different phases for the eventual
development our kind of medicine so
always I think the important thing is
the the basic science part so we are
studying that Human Development and
motoring the development we can be troll
or we can make make a new complex organ
structures so we have still many
challenges which I am going to be going
to highlight in the lightest right so we
still create these basic science
components as a major driver but I think
equally important the prototyping of a
second phase is also important so so for
instance I think if you use the Illinois
for the drug screening I think we need
to show the the positive evidence to
predict the human clinical trials and
also negative evidence to to predict the
human outcomes which for instance the
drugs are failed in the clinical studies
has to be leaked aperture edit in a
diseased organ conditions and so I think
we need to show the total preliminary
evidence for the the organoid based
application of the project prototyping
stage and if you see the very promising
potential I think we can move for move
forward or move further for the
translation so so we are currently
working on the transplant application of
liver overnight so we are working with
the large-scale production protocols or
larger animal model to test efficacy or
safety in preclinical conditions to
treatment for and also some of the
e-commerce prototyping has a potential
for the industrialization
so some case I think we are developing a
serbs in some case we are wising singled
to the companies to facilitate the
commercial application of organoid
or for improving the accessibility for
the many scientists or clinicians to use
organic based approaches so I'm jumping
into the the basic science part which I
am running in my laboratory in
Cincinnati so the questions we are
working up on Sentinel Children's is
very simple so how we can know the
process of organogenesis and how we
model that complex process by using the
human stem cell culture system so this
is the top question for you're still
dealing with so you know be the overall
I think the organ is really driven by
the basic developmental biology so I
would say translational and urology is
really key for the orgonite development
so you know the e gastrulation
is the de the old the initiation of the
human development or every development
development and afterwards we need
tissues are specified into the
progenitor stage including the endoderm
or Exeter or mesoderm so we are
particularly interested in the forged
end order which is diverse from the
early primitive endoderm structures so
forged endoderm is really giving rise to
a variety of different organs including
the thyroid itself on us in run and so
forth but we are specifically interested
in the border between the four got
pickup and posterior folded portion is
giving rise to the number of critical
organs for the metamerism including
liver tissues behavior issues or ventral
conquering population or those are
pancreas as well so so what we are
working on is using the human stem cells
to model the molecular Raj X which is
identified the classical development the
biology to to to leverage that in a stem
cell culture model to develop a design
principles for Lou cabbage reading the
human origin assess indentation so
buckling 2013 we are initially focusing
on the most premium process of liberal
but formation or early beaver
development so I will leave
is actually specified from the part of
Paseo forgot to so also this stage of
the population is named hepatic
specified in the normal cells and this
is about e95 just before a 95 in the
mouth or one month after gestation in
Shermans and hepatic specified and
themselves at this stage in two
dimensional sheet right structures but
but afterwards they are forming on the
robot structures which is clearly a 3d
and very complex structures increasingly
these 2d to 3d transitions is requiring
the support by the additional supporting
religions including endothelial cells
and also the mesenchymal populations
which is really found by the doctor
Kendall at groups and once this Reba bar
is formed in 3d conditions the blood
perfusion is initiated afterwards and
this is really critical for pushing the
cells to be more mature and finally
developing and complete mature
functional liver tissue structures so
what we are hypothesizing is quite
simple so
can we model the 3d to 3d transitions by
recapitulating these mainly a different
projector interaction in vitro in
cultured and if that is true
can we push the maturation of immaturity
of live organ but in vivo by producing
the the structure from the circulations
in vivo so so this is basically a two
step hypothesis so human iPS cells are
directly differentiated into the
multiple challengers in mixed in well to
see if we can make her cell phone and I
still can but in vitro and if we can
make it
can we transplant into the animal model
to see if we can get a maturity choosing
in vivo so some thanks right is simple
or summary of what we are working on
initially so working with the human iPS
cells on their feet of lee is provided
by dr. Shinya Yamanaka which is actually
clinical grade so or directly
differentiated into the three major
witnesses in vitro
I think the ah to the right I think we
I'm just showing the animation or movies
for the self-organization process but
it's not really coming up but anyway
using three different regions including
the transitional hepatic animal
population primarily marked by the tb-3
in septum mesenchyme population marked
by the wt1
and primitive endothelial cell
population marked by ICD so d1 will be
eco hearing we are able to make her
three critical ingredient for the view
about formations and using that three
percent of population we are able to
make us really miniature we robot
structures in vitro so the next right is
showing the structure of these are bit
relieved about Reich structures so in
this pictures are let is a human
in the do tools differentiate it from
the IPS cells and the green one is a
hepatic progenitor population made but
made by the human iPS cells and this is
not really just a simple cluster if this
is aggregate you want to see the very
first purchase but it's not so so they
are developing Network Reich structures
from the red marked endothelial cell
populations and aligned with these
beautiful of networks right structures
are we see the hepatic cells align in a
beautiful modern so this is a clearly
and no signs of self organizations so we
return these structures as vascular eyes
leave about organize made by a bit of 3d
culture system so we also characterized
by tissue sections or single-cell
analysis and so forth to confirm this
fraction is livery close to the bebo
liver right issues involving bebo but
you know we there are critical signs of
self-organization like professional
networks we are expecting decisions can
be transplanted in bebo so that next
right shows the vivo outcomes
so okay so this is the transplanted
liberal about tissues and and this
whitish per is the about one centimeter
in size and this is day zero after two
days or three days entire part get reps
which really suggesting the blood cells
not perfusing the entire structures made
by the human iPS cells in the mouths of
immunodeficient background so once the
broth fusion is initiated after two or
three days or 48 hours well 72 hours the
blood vessels are remodeled over time to
form a more sophisticated purposes
structures so the next ride is
confirming VD I've shown a professional
network so so in this way the the
dextran may be a green one for blue one
is the proper fusion in the mouth and
red and green our red and orange in the
human cell component so if you zoom in
up other tissues
if it's coming out cold okay so so this
is the to the right needs the human
ideas and do networks so so so this is
just a confirm entire vascular
structures for by the human cells or
human iPS cells but profusion words are
shaded by the mouse calculations so I
literally thought we the to the right I
think that has to be animations for
confirming the chimeric personal
information between the human vessels
and in Mouse vessels it's not coming out
so skipping into the next right
okay
I think there are animation as well
though so this is just to to show you
the the transplant process of liver
about all them are into the animal model
but it's not coming up so I'm skipping
this and to the bottom this is a
transformer liebherr but
okay so this is a number of leave Oba
are transplanted onto the methane 3
communications which is close to the
polar main and to the right this is the
couple - of Ivo car and in the sham
group is as shown in here indicated by
Bluebird and after 30 days we most of
the nose is dying overtime after 30 days
but but if you transplant the human
liver organ on into this location or
missing to experimentations is rescuing
the river failure or which is result
indicated by red color so this we we
simply suggesting that the the most of
the surviving mouse rescued by the
functional replacement by the liver
transplantation and this is a
therapeutic prototype of the concept of
the legal organizations and but I think
this approaches is really I think a
universal or generalizable for the other
tissue as well so we are working on the
other tissue organ and model as well
including the gut tissues lung tissues
kidney tissues or cardiac or brain and
also diseased tissues like cancer so for
3d culture approaches is in aving entire
tissues to be pasteurized in vitro and
to form a 1 centimetre tissues in vitro
and if you transfer into the mouse using
the human cells again we are able to
pasteurize after 48 hours of
transplantation in in this bisoder
LaMotta over time as well and i think
one of the most remarkable organ where
the kidney because i thinkI knee has a
very tremendous of a powerful potential
for the in vivo self organizations so
this is just a macroscopic confocal live
imaging analysis or for generated
kidney but transplant and green marks
fishing
mouse-kini cells and web marks 3d
purpose house
to combine as you see here in the middle
I think very small tiny glimmer Iraq
structures are beautifully formed from
the scratch and this is really I think
remarkable aspect of the Ocampa
transplantation approaches and also we
are working on a pancreatic model as
well and as you see here to the left is
also be the movie for a time-lapse movie
for the contradict vascular eyes of an
inflammation process but again I don't
need to see any videos so I can skip
your hair down as well and this is the
the middle is the the microscopic view
of the generated basket right pancreatic
islet and that can be transplanted into
the capsule of the kidney and using that
transportation model we are comparing
the computing potential against the
luminal diabetes model in the MUX
so to the bottom cover by again survival
curve showing the luminal diabetes is
very severe because after four or five
days without transplantation most of the
mouse is just dying but if you transfer
the mouse
primary I read indicated by Bluebird
this transplant approaches is a victim
to some extent so almost 50% oh the
mouse is recovering from the permanent
diabetes if you transport the mouse I
read but you know we I think nitrate
transplantation is very promising and
because of the promise is actually
tested in humans or clinics as well but
the problem is the pasteurization Oralia
Grossmont so so I read transplantation
is locking the basket errs so if you
combine in with our all the bit based
approaches we are expecting that
transparent efficiency might be improved
and because of that indicated by red bar
the basket riser I read transplantation
using our oven but culture approaches is
really improving the efficacy of I read
transplant patients as indicated by a
red LED bird
this simply suggesting the transplant
efficiency is really important for the
therapeutic potential against the
diabetes conditions so having that
product concept demonstrations we are
now working in primarily working on the
liberal organ transplantation to leskew
the disease patients in final part of my
basic science is I think the next very
big challenge in in a hole in our field
so currently Olga no scientist is just
looking at the single organ to generate
so in our case we are working on the
liver tissue generation from the scratch
was themselves but I say I think the
single open generation approach is quite
limited in terms of the longer are in
vitro maturation or longer in vivo
functionalization because if you have
defects in the surrounding structures
like very portion or bile duct or or
pancreas I think we have liver failed
what we have damaged the liver tissues
in vivo in a clinical conditions so you
know the sort of interurban connections
or multi organ connections might be I
think the next basic science challenge
to to go forward so so Hilo Kawika
working in my laboratory in Cincinnati
spearheaded this problem so he's working
on the more complex organ a model and he
recently found the deep so this is a
reporter human ideas minds leaving the
human proc swamp genes by RFP using this
reporter system he was able to four from
the posterior forget to make Nick ticks
ruptures including a liver tissues as
well as a media report or duodenum
potion as well so so to the right this
is the home on Toledo staining and of
the products one which is a hepatic
portion and DVA is the BDA portion so
combined with two colors we are able to
show the functional
next we deliver on video trucks and also
we have a pancreatic to video ring
connections as well as the biliary to
intestinal connection as well so this is
a microscopic view of ramiro survived
human organ oil as well as the mouse
wheel in people structures which is
closely resembling the human ideas all
monoi based approaches so I think this
kind of proof of concept approach is
really important for looking at the
expanding the potential for other organs
as well like any richer bladder
connection to a central nervous system
to the paper'll
number system connections or lung to
airway connections and so forth so I
think this is a sort of very important
challenge to go forward so this is just
a basic science borrow olive tree but
now from now I'm switching a little bit
for the transformational applications
namely and older medicine so you don't
be organ or can be developed from the
patient specific stem cell so a healthy
person their lives themselves
so using that tissues I think we can
study the human specific biology has a
basic science but more importantly I
think we can use these dishes as other
to the human disease conditions so
having that are better I think we are
able to monitor the disease progressions
or disease prevention or disease
treatment in vitro so so having that
approaches I think we can envision the
precision medicine application on drug
testing application in pharmaceutical
industries and ultimately using a
healthier stem cell organized I think we
can transfer boxes of patients to see if
we can rescue the disease conditions so
we can we can foresee a number of
different applications using the Roman
based approaches in my lab particularly
interested in the liver organize so we
initially targeting the application to
the drug development process you know
the hepatotoxicity is a very bottleneck
or critical hurdles for the drug
development process especially in the
later stage of clinical trials if you
have some time
defects related to the liver toxicity I
think this will be causing a tremendous
loss of the DES money and also the time
for the development so if you can
predict the hepatotoxicity in a human
specific condition I think that would be
really a tremendous for the much
development process another phase to the
next step I think we can also use
they're not just our safety and
screening but also we can use and tissue
form the frequency screening structures
have started Politis which is a growing
medical our problems for the number of
different countries and also we can use
the tissues for the new potentially for
the nutrition nutritional screening for
the Prevention's and also we can use the
extra capri or device to be integrated
by the old line to to to use the tissues
as a sort of supporting device for the
liver failure but as a phase three or
last ways I think we can use a tissue
for the transplant patients we account
retargeting the congenital metallica
eller of the the patients can be treated
by Aldrin transplantation
so I would focus on the two main
application in my talk the first one is
a drug efficacy screening so as I said I
think the cells of papyrus were
non-alcoholic stent modalities is really
a growing concern in many different
countries so in particularly in the
United States
I think Nash or set up at allit is now
leading goals for the liver transplant
patients so clearly we need a high high
volume medical needs to be created by by
some medications but currently there are
no available surprisingly no available
effective drugs to treat the nash
conditions although they are estimated
to be opening up a huge market for for
the future drug industries I think this
is partly because we are looking at
effective human model to to to to the
capital
right the center panel is conditioning
vigil so we are hoping to use over nine
to model the mash conditions in vitro so
we SP are headed this problem as well
so initially we have developed a method
to make a multi cellular organelle or Oh
including the innate immunity population
or macrophage population can we Co
develop in our liver all-women
conditions so so having the immune
components for she hypothesize to see we
can recapitulate the entire process of
the distemper tidies so set the
politeness is initially initiated upon
the hepatocytes lipid accumulation or
name reassess step ptosis but but if you
get the lipid accumulated over time I
think they are activating somehow the
infantry process triggered by the
macrophage or liberal resident
macrophage like Cooper cell and after
the inflammatory steam rides continues I
think the hepatocyte is getting stressed
out and cytoskeleton a disorganized and
the mitochondria are overloaded and
eventually
developed by the fibrotic population is
expanded waiting to necrosis
so we exposed a number of ingredients to
trigger the statuses as well as the
information and the suite in suit to see
if we can make an fibrotic condition in
vitro by continued a lipid stimulation
in vitro so so this is just an basic
hello my model we are currently working
on so we have I think this should be
also moving for an illiberal information
process so so we are devising we all got
a model from the human iPS cells to
model the micron now I'm not an anatomy
of the human liver tissues so we have
biliary canonicalized structures which
is a very important folder by acid
secretions and we have by transport
polarized a good movement of the human
limo organized and we have tight
junction proteins as well and this is
really close to the actual in vivo
biometric sirs indicated by e/m analysis
and having that organ or tissue x' I
think we are able to look at the bio
acid transport visualized by the
fluorescent my asset method based assays
so we are able to visualize by by likely
imaging to monitor the bio acid
excretion pathways in our neural level
so this is a very I think important for
the multiple liberal based applications
and in this some kind of model has a
very unique advantage because we have
multicellular configurations so so the
majority of cells are composed by the
humans other side indicated by the EP
cam this is a stereo cell markers so
eighty percent actually the hepatocytes
but out of the twenty percent
I think the half of the population these
are al she I am I'll come positive or CD
166 positive Stuart Reich cell ranges
which is amazing kind of cell population
residing in a nubuck tissues and in into
the bottom I think more less minor
population but we do see the produced
ball or email one positive kupah reg
cell population is also called developed
in these liberal structures so to the
right this is a whole mountain you know
staining or the single level humanoid
and as you see here majority is a EP cam
or equal hearing or C EB P alpha
positive we have outside populations but
some of the soldier of I mention concept
mesenchymal cell population responsible
for eventual fibrosis as well as the
cd68 macrophage population is call
developed in these three well organized
structures so having that multicellular
configurations index are exposed Park or
or carbohydrates in vitro to see if we
can induce the cell
so we'll do the left I think this is
also the live imaging apology like
analysis in our organ so if you expose
the fat or carbohydrates in a higher
level or we are able to show the mass
evacuation or try gristle I indicated by
the green one in the bottom figure and
this is really those abandoned so if you
do not really modify the Culture Media I
think they never get any triglyceride a
cube or anything but if you increase the
dose of fatty acid as well as the
carbohydrates we are able to equip me
right extensively into the liver organ
if you continue this lipid accumulated
conditions we are able to show the
preliminary fibrosis like a phenotype in
vitro so party no H is a Muslim Frankel
abstaining and after seven days we see
some collagen depositions and then a
panel I is also the immunostaining of
the whole mount tissues analysis and
green one is the fibrotic population and
that one is like videos on populations
who combined I think we see the fibrosis
our fiber optic cell population are
propagated in our older model in
parallel J is a biochemical analysis of
the supernatant so so this is a pro
chronic peptide which is also used in
the clinics to diagnose the fibrosis and
this biomarker is also increased in our
set but I dislike organ on Culture Media
combined I think how organ is probably
able to model the preliminary aspects of
the status or fibrosis additional
specific conditions how much predictive
in this organic model so to test that I
think we are using the general generic
contribution to be predicted in in an
over model so so to test that we are
looking at the three major volumes
reported by
others publishing the Nature Genetics
bugling 2017 last year so also using
these three major most significant
volumes we are stratifying or make a
better ranking of 25 hundreds of
genotype available since Enron and it
made a list ratifying panel so highly
patience Crimson rinds and middle risk
patient stem cell lines or minimal risk
well Louis Simpson right to see if we
can borrow that genetic conditions in a
selected couple steps around into the
right this is a triglyceride staining
you know over level using the different
risk patient populations and as you see
here high risk patient stem cell
organoid
is accumulating we try chrysolite much
higher extent than the middle risks
themselves were all these custom cell
derived all the time so this mu e is
simply suggesting that genetic factors
identified by the hundred thousands of
patients on genotype analysis can be
predicted by the couple would different
stem cell right analysis in older level
so this is I think very remarkable to
predict the phenotype in humans using
the probe Simpson right so so having
that collaboration in the tumors we now
test the critical are trials like
conditions in vitro using the ich and
retesting compounds Michael very colic
acid as well as f0 nineteen so to the
left this is like a fickle see analysis
like copper mining a survival car and
but this is an organized survival curve
so so if you look at the ha blue or
light blue bar this is a non drug
treated condition so this is like a sham
group so all Ghana is eventually dying
off over time but if you expose the
ovary kolakozhi or FC of 90 which is
remarkably improving the survival after
the state o Systema right as the answer
indicator
by the pink as well as dark gray and if
you do not really expose the fat I think
they are surviving all the time so this
really are highlighting the organoid
base to survival outcomes these are
somehow familiar to the clinical trials
that they contain 3/4 Nash but not just
for the efficacy like analysis I think
we can use their survival and I for the
father mechanistic studies so for
instance this is comparing the reactive
oxygen species which is also the trigger
for the increment reprocess in a
hepatocytes so so we see the massive
iteration of reactive oxygen species in
fact reading Illinois but that can be a
improved or decreased by the oh very
cool like acid treatment or 6:19
treatment as well and this is the
quantitative analysis and also I'm not
going to go into detail because of the
time limitations but below fibrosis can
be predicted by the stiffness
measurements for old annoyed if you look
at the state of pathologies overnight
the untreated one is very low but if you
increase the fibrosis night conditions
in organoid the stiffness is really
highly appreciated as indicated by the
blue bar but but that stiffness increase
can be also turns out or you hitted by
the extreme 17 or also Alberta colic
acid so this is really it's just ink
highlighting that potential for the
clinical trials like condition in the
dish so by multiplying the genetic
factors as well as lifestyle fractures
or screening practice we are able to
conduct human organ oil-based trials or
hope trials which we think for the
efficacy screening in vitro in the
future and we also give up in the higher
who put for for measuring the stiffness
measurements which is not really showing
up here and also we are working on the
sort of all digital solution to be
degraded to to monitored in a y OS
manner and so forth but
we are expecting in the future although
no trials can be very meaningful to for
the clinical trials and as a last part
of my presentation is focused in a phase
three application which is namely a
transplantations so I think called
annoying or over but transplantation is
sort of intermediate approaches between
currently preparing old and transplant
as well as the hepatocytes or cell
transplantation so this is the organ I
transplanted transplantations what we
want to prove is to make a functional
alga by transplanting very immature
tissues or very immature organized to
see if we can eventually let's get the
metal clipper disease so I think there
are a couple reading initiative working
on the transplantations I think Tokyo
medical dental University which is also
my second of creation and but not my
group but different group is also
working on the transplantation or whole
annoyed initially targeting of the
inflammatory bowel disease using adult
stem cell Illinois and also the nasal
run for European group or our group or
Sentinel Children's is also working on
the hold on transplantation application
for trading we currently truck scible
disease so I think in the next ride is
just a simple bill or what we want to do
in the future this is quite simple so
Olga my manufacturing and transplant
into the patients hopefully transplant
are avenged or within a couple years so
this is simple but I think it's really
challenging because number of different
components for organ or production has
to be supported by the industry partners
because I think we need to have critical
green media we have to have clinical
grade culture parades well we have to
develop clinical predicting preclinical
animal model or the small loader model
or sometimes incurring the large animal
model as well and we have to develop
critical valuation protocols by
microscopic analysis as well as other
biochemical assays and probably we
somehow need a robotic support
or skating up the process so so this is
really I think very challenging and too
too much for the academic sign this so
we need a collaborative networks by
working with the number of different
industry partners to do that so I'm just
showing a couple of different example of
the collaboration with the companies so
so this is the the our mass production
platform by collaborating with Z with
the chemical companies called a cool
alight so we have developed a critical
grey a micro well pray which is over the
well one well la pray form where we
wearing we have the 20,000 micro wells
are placed over the well praise and we
can make a very homogeneous beautiful or
miniature whole economy structures in a
single culture time into the right this
is the collective human liberal annoying
from the purple stem cell just showing
you the homogeneous tissue can before in
a very large-scale manner so we have the
mass production platform and also be
wrecking on the robotic companies to
make GMP manufacturing facilities so
this Airport was primarily ended by dr.
Taniguchi working in a conversation
University in collaboration with my
level 3 and as you see I think this also
the movie but but we have the logic
automatic machines to to make our
hundred so for Cogan can be manufactured
in a continuous manner in a nice random
manner which is a conical grade so
having that collaborations we are hoping
to transplant back to the patients
within the next few years by initially
targeting the US cycle disorders so for
this particular applications we are
using the human iPS cells provided by
the coder University I think as you
already aware but dr. June Takahashi at
Cairo University initiated the clinical
trials using this particular IPS run for
the Parkinson disease last week actually
this is very a quite exciting but using
the same IPS mine they are using we
are also preparing for the clinical
trials for the liver disease by
developing a GMP grade manufacturing
process and transmitted back to the
patient to see if we can improve the
clinical outcomes so so within the other
three indications I think we have
tremendous demand so as I highlight it
in a background right we have over four
thousands of patients on just nine
during the waiting period for the liver
transplantation and but this is really
underestimated I think and also we have
multiple different countries waiting for
the liver transplantation so I think I
think too fair to be fair I think
currently overall 68 over almost hundred
thousands of the patients are waiting to
die for the liver transplantation so I
think this patient population can be
obviously the indication for even for
the challenging organization approaches
but within this sort of absolute
indication thinking we can open up a
very large promising market for the puny
creature commercialization so so this is
just a summary of my talk and I think in
the future I think we can transfer back
to the patient especially in a very end
stage or a very Claddagh core organ
failure condition which we can certainly
transplant organized into the patients
but I think organ transplantation or
cell copy product is really expensive so
I think we need to know down the
indications to really specifically
targeting the patients who cannot really
created by other modalities but I think
majority of the patients is benefited by
the precision medicine applications on
drug treatment so I think organ is
really meaningful to still for drug
screening or precision type of
applications so this is a just a sort of
overall big picture of what we are
predicting in your future by using organ
medicine applications with that I'd like
to thank all my members in the
laboratories as well as the
collaborators and thank you so much for
your attention and happy to take some
questions
you
thank you doctor to cafe for that really
amazing presentation so will now begin
the live question-and-answer portion of
this webinar so I'd like to remind you
again if you do have a question that
you'd like to ask please do so now by
clicking on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
in the box that appears on your screen
and then just click the send button so
with that let's get started so back to
the cafe we we do have a few questions
here one of the questions that has come
in is what do you think are the
technologies that will be driving your
organoids
4.0
you
okay so you were asking about this
question number two question tray number
eight okay
Technologies will be driving over a foot
point at all so I think I think I think
it's it's there are a couple differences
depending on the application so for
instance I think drug screening
application I think technologies we are
lacking is the sort of higher throughput
screening system so so for instance I
think in our organizing the live imaging
approaches or live stiffness measuring
approaches to predict a certain Politis
conditions but I think still I think the
throughput is limited to two tests I
think at best I think we can test the
hundreds of compounds in organ level but
in a real world or in a your drug
screening companies I think they are
testing over hundreds of thousands of
compounds in a cell line model so we
need to increase the throughput
extensively so for the particular drug
screening application I think we what we
are lacking or what we need is for the
higher throughput instruments to measure
the the organized readout in a higher
speed so that with that I think we are
collaborating with the solo flower micro
robotics scientist or micro fluidics
scientist to to make our make this
happen so so I think depending on
applications but particularly for the
drug screening I think we microfluidic
type of application is really important
but up for the transfer brackish
transplant application is really
different so so transplantation is
really critically driven by the I think
the mass production in a clinical grade
so just making them tissues in a larger
scale is quite easy
I think but but in a critical grade
manufacturing process is I think really
challenging because we need a validation
protocols or and also we have to
manufacture in a very clean or very
critical grade and facility
to make sure they are pretty safe and
also we need to test all of the
mass-produced tissues in the animal
model to confirm the safety to make sure
we do not really develop a tumors or
uncontrollable or cancer liked issues in
beeble so clinical grade manufacturing
or mass production is really critical
technologies we are still dealing with
for the transplant application so it's
really depending on the application but
I think there are a couple of key
hurdles still existing and how far away
do you think that kind of technology is
is this something you think we'll see in
the next couple of years another five to
ten years so yes we are we are actually
planning to transparent and within three
years from now so we are almost in the
final process of the manufacturing
process as well as the valuation process
so currently we are printing on the
safety trials with the period because
it's with the aim of obtaining the
efficacy signals Prakriti advocacy
analysis we are planning on twenty
twenty or twenty twenty-one to be
initiated so it's not really for our
future and for the precision medicine I
think as you already know the cystic
fibrosis application is already
initiated in a Han screamers group in a
nether run so so they're using the
organization's for model or predict the
human condition Meena cystic fibrosis to
derive organ on and they are actually
selecting the effective drugs and now
treated by the drugs selected by the
holder so for the procedural medicine I
think it's already happening so so it's
not really far future I think it's very
tangible feature
thanks for that and it's actually kind
of a good segue to one of the other
questions that is here as it relates to
adult tissue derives organize models as
you know some of the other models that
are out there there's an adult tissue
derived liver organized model as well
perhaps you could compare your model
with that model what you think the sort
of the advantages and disadvantages are
of the existing models today
thank you so much I think this is really
important so I think we have good and
bad so for the IPS or ESL divine Morgana
model has a advantage for the bounty
cellular configuration so I think mostly
the adult issues revive going on is a
serial cell structures so we have a
couple of cell types but mostly I
ethereal cell types but IPS or es cell
based approach we are able to co-develop
supportive regions including the
mesenchymal components and also immune
components and in addition to that we
have material components so
multicellular configuration is I think
important but downside of organoid from
the IPS or PSC is the I think maturation
stage so you know the adult stem cell is
a doubt device but IPS or AES all this
is from the the umbrella sore or egg
station so it's really freaked out Fito
an embryonic stage so functionality hold
the e IPS or PSC model is a little bit
immature or completely less mature than
adult stem cell organoid so for the drug
screening application or some of the
organ functions is a little difficult to
you to predicting a PSC base model but
can do with the adult stem cell on a
model but interestingly I think for the
transplantation
I think the adult each to divide is a
little difficult and grafting vivo
probably because of the lack of
supporting components and probably
because the immaturity is really
important for the eventual investment so
so I think well for the transplant
application we are intentionally using
the immature or less mature organized
tissues for the transplantation to
improve the vivo outcomes so it's there
many still arguable points for the aps-c
divisor or adult stem cell derived organ
a model but what each has a different
advantage for the different applications
I think we have time for for just
another question here so a question that
this just came in is asking regarding
transplantation into liver disease
patients have you estimated just how
many organized you would actually need
to transplant to have a therapeutic
benefit
thank you so much so so here we we are
turning to trance trance over I think
100 thousands of organoid for patients
with the congenital disease for the kids
so which is equivalent to the 10 to the
eighth or or less than 10 to the nine
cell or number equilibrant hyper side
agreement so this number is actually
determined by the previous critical
trials of the primary hepatocytes
transplantation actually are implemented
in the clinics so for the hepatocytes
plantation I think the in the clinics
the physicians are transplanting over
ten to the eight hepatocytes into the
patient and already see the benefit from
that disease conditions so so we are
probably initially planning to
transplant a great number of the
parasite transplantation which is about
hundreds of thousands of old annoyed to
3d said clinical trials thank you so
much for asking the questions that is a
lot of organized yes it's a lot so so
with that we'll we'll bring this webinar
to a close once again I'd like to thank
dr. tick FA for his Israeli excellent
presentation here and before we go
please note that today's webinar will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February 2019 and thank you all for
joining us and we hope you enjoy the
rest of today's event
thank you so much bye-bye